[Applause]
she is the editor-at-large at recode
host of the podcast recode decode and
contributing opinion writer for The New
York Times Kara Swisher Hey
[Music]
great to meet you are you doing thank
you for being here you do a hell of a
job thank you
keeping the tech sector honest and I
read this week that the Facebook and
Twitter I guess removed a lot of fake
accounts yeah finally okay so this is a
layman's question I am not very tech
savvy I got a lot of my knowledge from
you but you know you need ID to buy
groceries yes you do we know that
why don't you need ID to prove who you
really are on Facebook or Twitter
because it wouldn't make them so many
billions of dollars I guess I don't know
I mean it's a really problematic that's
the only reason that's the only reason
is that this has been a thing that's
been built from the beginning to operate
the way it does which was is to do
growth growth growth at all cost and
also take away your data privacy from
you and that's what it does so there's
no way we can shame them into doing the
right thing
well they're under attack because you
know the country's under attack yes this
is the modern way of warfare it's not
artillery anymore from Russia yeah I
wrote a column in The Times talking
about this idea of values and standards
and the fact that they had to get some
they had to have them but for what I
thought was I did a podcast just
recently with Mark Zuckerberg and one of
the things when we talked about it was
the was the idea of what was going on
and whether he had responsibility for
the platform a lot of these people don't
feel like they have responsibility he
doesn't well it's a weird thing they do
now if you notice when he was in
Congress he said I we have a broader
responsibility and my question when he
was saying that to all those those
various politicians was why didn't he
have it in the first place why didn't
they start by building these things so
that they would be that they would they
would evolve in a way that kept pace
with humanity's and when I realized when
I was talking to him was that he didn't
take humanities in college he didn't
finish college and instead became a
billionaire so they don't have a great
sense of their the impact of the things
they built well also I think we've
romanticized nerds yes we have you know
back when I was in college nerd was a
bad word and then it became though this
cute thing right you know hot girls like
to say I'm a nerd
you're not you know and I know it's not
really always a good thing I mean Mark
Zuckerberg I'm sorry but that is a real
nerd he looks awful he just closed yeah
closer terrible he's poor I mean Bill
Gates looks like Cary Grant really right
you know he's you know he's on this
spectrum of dweeb enos that I don't
think ya know I just hey now bill what
two consultants looks you can insult his
entire service and the way it's ruined
democracy but please don't insult his
looks he's not watching they're not
watching say they plug him in at night
in the car no no but I'm just saying
what when people are nerds I think they
just have you know that's what part of
nerdiness is you just you have trouble
relating to humanity and I don't think
they very often have a great sense of
humor yeah it's called an EQ they don't
it is that they don't I try to talk to
them in the language they talk to so I
often try to use like Marvel Comics and
various things like that what I like to
do is this idea which is actually a
Voltaire quote but I don't bring that
into the discussion with them which is
with great power comes great
responsibility which is uncle the Peter
Parker's uncle and so I keep saying to
them I said you have abrogated your
responsibility when you built these
things and the way you built them made
them so they would operate this way and
so when you think about it these sites
were not hacked by the Russians they
were used exactly as they were built
right there was no hacking you and the
Russians walked right in companies never
just do the right thing because you
asked them you have to find them you
have to you have to you have to regulate
them did you watch those hearings
there's more coming up but did you watch
it how do you think mark did like you
don't make me talking about mark dr.
Berger I mean all of them they're all
coming there what happens is it's a
student incredibly low bar because
politicians are absolutely brain dead
when it comes to tech especially and so
what they do is they ask questions
during that particular hearing it was
about Terms of Service it was as if
terms of service were the biggest
national security crisis of our time
like that you can't read them that
they're super confusing did Facebook
start out as something very sexist
wasn't it I'm getting the movie don't go
with the movie it wasn't it wasn't
something but they were just raiding the
well that's horrible
yeah but that wasn't what Facebook was
then that was his first thing we don't
want to be judged by our first things
bill that did you think about is is when
you think about responsibility they they
don't think there's consequences so they
they don't think about the consequences
of what they created and what they
invented and one of the Facebook's
biggest things that were on the walls if
you go to Facebook headquarters first of
all these all these headquarters are
built less as if they're 412 mill boys
essentially all kinds of you know slides
and things like that on the wall one
time they asked me to go down and slide
and I'm like I'm not going down you're
[ __ ] years old I'm not gonna like it
now but they have on the wall they have
this thing that said move fast and break
things I think you've all seen that it's
the move and they were all excited about
move fast and break things and when you
think about it you go
well you've broken a lot of things now
what are you gonna fix but their
mentality was that right break things
break things yeah so they broke
democracy but okay yeah no they didn't I
mean it they're part of it I mean the
whole all the things we were talking
about before what Donald Trump is doing
these are part of that but what social
media does is it amplifies and what I
said in The Times was that it weaponized
is everything it weaponized is the First
Amendment it weaponized in social media
it weaponized is social discourse and it
creates a disc and it weaponized is
discord and that's that's the problem
and that's what the Russians took
advantage of